city dubbed America's most dangerous and
it's I otago is not the most dangerous
city in America Camden New Jersey has
that kind a lot of time an area that has
been labeled drug offense the wiring
Andrews murder rate has more than
doubled this year compared to last life
here in Camden is is dangerous life here
in Camden is deadly for every moment for
every second that the kids are out here
playing they're not getting shot at for
every second that they're here they're
not witnessing something I can get them
hurt later on the stakes are playing and
right in front of us for kids that
aren't participating you know they're
hustling for kids that are participating
in the league they're safe
when I was a kid the expectation was
that you would play baseball that Pine
Point Park would be a part of who you
were and what you did but by the time
I'd become a teenager there was this
expectation that young men my age would
become the bread owners by going out
onto the corners we were right in the
midst of the crack wars and so most of
the young men that had once played
baseball we're now on the corners and
most of the people that had coach were
now using I dropped out of high school
and began dealing drugs like many of my
counterparts I would eventually be
arrested and incarcerated and end up
serving about eight years in New Jersey
State Prison when I came home it was
truly with the sense that I had to give
something back so I came up with the
idea of baseball
baseball hadn't been played in Camden
for almost two decades but I knew that
there was still a connection here in
this neighborhood and hearing this city
with the sport so I said look if the
city is going to be crazy if the
neighborhood is going to be on fire
let's try to create one safe place for
kids in the neighborhood and let's start
a baseball league
[Music]
hey Joseph Brian just call him see if
you had a practice tonight with the
softball mattify Khaimah Tex all the
other coaches you see who was practice
tonight and he once didn't still need
the catcher's game all right all right
see you there thank you when I started
coming out and saying hey we're going to
play baseball I used to get people
looking at me like I was crazy but I had
to be that leader and in many instances
I had to be fearless and be the one
willing to go up to ask the drug dealer
you know between these hours would you
mind not hustling that's just what we
had to do in overtime the hustling fell
by the wayside and we became the norm in
the park as you go they should go all
right college boy when we started we
ended up with a hundred kids that year
and it blew our minds today we have over
650 kids playing and that's kids playing
from age five all the way up to age 18
if you set back and close your eyes you
just hear the ping or the crack of the
older kids when you use their wood bat
the sound of the ball hitting leather
cleats
scraping the gravel kids rattling on the
fence you know cheering go batter batter
batter
people usually yell and scream because
something was wrong and now people are
yelling and screaming because something
fantastic is happening come game time
it's the most beautiful thing in the
world
so that is going to teach you today how
to hit off the batting team all right as
a father who tells his daughter
constantly that you can do anything that
you want and be anything you want you
know you look up and and you want to
help you remember why you're doing it
all right so much of our life in Camden
and so much of our lives in our urban
cores is being hard but kids for the few
hours that they're here they're just
free to act out and become whatever hero
they want to be they're just free to
laugh it's not always going to be easy
and there are forces at play that they
would love to see me fail I have to
continue to dig deep and put the grind
in because I just I just know I got to
do it come on if I don't do it no one
else is going to do it you know I tell
myself there's plenty of time to rest
when I'm dead until then I'm going to
live life to the fullest
[Music]